[موسيقى]
نعم توقفوا عن اصدار البيانات او فيما يخص
المعلومات الحساسه فمثلا لاحصل على الكثير
المعلومات فيما يخص الموازنات او الحوالات
الماليه وسقط ماليه واين الاموال مثلا
لانهم لا يريدون لهذه المسائل انها تكون
معرضه لعقوبه جديده قضينا وقتا طويلا
لمراجعه كل معلومه التي يمكننا مراجعتها
فمثلا من جهه بيانات التجاره ليس من السيء
مراجعه هذه البيانات لان البيانات التجاره
نحصل عليها من الدول العميله مثلا الهند
والصين والامارات العربيه المتحده وتركيا
وغيرها فيكون لدينا اطباء جيد عن الارقام
الروسيه انها صحيحه او لا وبالفعل كانت
صحيحه لان استطيع ان نراجع حساباته
والارقام من دول اخرى
وانا في موسكو
واسافر
عبر المنطقه وحتى في مرقه مختلفه من روسيا
فلنستطيع ان
نرى لو كان هنالك اثر على الاقتصاد فبلاك
سنلاحظ مثلا بعض محاله التسوق الكبير او
المحلات الغربيه اغلقت والتي اغلقت لفتره
والبعض عده افتتاحها باسماء مختلفه ولكن
لا يوجد اي احساس بالانخفاض او الانحدار
الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
لا احد يتحدث عن خساره الوظائف او انخفاض
في الدخل في الحقيقه لمن يعيش في موسكو
الان
ولم يقرا الاخبار العالميه فما كان ليعرف
ان هنالك نزاع اصلا فلم يتغير الكثير
للحياه اليوميه
للشعب الروسي
فيما يخص الظروف المعيشيه حصولهم على
الدعم الاجتماعي والوظائفه وغيرها لم
يتغير الكثير على الارض
خلال العام الماضي
ولكن بلا شك نحن ندخل مرحله تحوليا حيث
العقوبات باتت اشد الان وبالتالي فان
الموقف في عام 23 بلا شك سيكون
او لا يصب كثيرا في مصلحه روسيا او اصعب
على اقتصاد الروسي ما كان عليه في عام
2022 لذلك اعتقد بان هذا العام اثر
العقوبات بلا شك سيكون اكثر وضوحا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]